Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 143. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ich begrüße euch wieder am Endgerät, ihr, die mich immer so empfängt. Und heute habe ich mir mal ein Thema ausgedacht, was so ein bisschen scary ist, zumindest für mich. Ich bin immer so, mit so bestimmten Sachen stehe ich dann doch ein wenig auf dem Kriegsfuß. Dazu gehört alles Biologische dazu. Und naja, da das ganz offensichtlich ein Thema ist, was ich sowieso nicht alleine bestreiten kann, dachte ich mir, hole ich mir gleich mal angemessene Verstärkung und begrüße Lisa. Lisa Thalheim, hallo. Hey Lisa, das ist gut, super. Ich glaube, wir haben noch nie eine Radiosendung zusammen gemacht, oder?
Möglicherweise in alten Chaosradio-Zeiten.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Oder auf jeden Fall mal wieder Zeit. Du bist ja auch schon ganz lange unterwegs, wie wir gerade festgestellt haben, und wir haben da auch so ein Gutstück gemeinsam gegangen. Sprich, du bist auch schon so Altschulhacker geworden. Kann man fast sagen, wenn man schon so lange sich mit Technik und Spaß am Gerät auseinandersetzt, wie du das machst. Vielleicht kannst du ja mal so ein bisschen was sagen, so zu deinem Einstieg in diese Welt. Womit hast du denn eigentlich losgelegt?
Losgelegt habe ich im zarten Alter von sechs Jahren am C64. Das beschränkte sich dann vor allen Dingen auf den ein oder anderen Befehl und ansonsten Spiele.
Die Befehle waren dann im Wesentlichen Load und Run.
Was man halt braucht, um an die Spiele ranzukommen.
Ja klar.
Und ja, später dann halt PCs, wobei ich da meinem Bruder zu danken habe. Der hat nämlich nur einen PC und ich bin immer um zwölf aus der Schule gekommen, so als kleines Zweit- und Drittklässler-Schnubbel. Und mein Bruder erst um vier und das hat ihn so angenervt, dass er nach Hause kam und dachte, er kann sich jetzt schön an den Computer setzen. Und dann saß er aber schon die kleine Schwester und daddelte. Also hat der Passwort-Sperren eingebaut, die sich erst ab Wochen tags ab 16 Uhr am Wochenende ab 11 Uhr freigegeben haben. Also hatte ich immer vier Stunden Zeit jeden Tag, mich mit dieser Passwort-Sperre zu beschäftigen. Und drei Iterationen davon haben wir geschafft. Und bei der dritten wusste ich dann nicht mehr weiter, da hat das mir dann am Ende doch noch gezeigt, wie man da drumherum kommt.
Und wie bist du denn… also die ersten Hürden hast du einfach durch Erraten?
Also die erste Hürde war durch Erraten. Das Passwort war der Spitzname, den er seiner Freundin gegeben hatte.
Aber er wollte schon eigentlich, dass du das Passwort nicht umgehst? Okay.
Und die nächsten Iterationen waren dann so DOS, Auto-Exec-Bat, F8 und so. Und mit 13 habe ich dann meinen eigenen Rechner bekommen. Und dann ging es auch so mit dem Programmieren ein bisschen weiter.
Das hat dich gleich gezeigt.
Also auch vorwiegend durch meinen Bruder, weil er schon früher, also das sind mehrere Älter, hat schon früher angefangen zu programmieren. Und ich fand das total toll, was mein großer Bruder da macht. Und wollte das unbedingt auch haben.
Und so bist du also schon sehr früh auch dann in Hackerkreise geraten. Und hast dich dann ja auch, mich recht erinnere, eigentlich sehr früh auch so mit, ja immer so eigentlich den moderneren Trendsportarten im Hackbereich auseinandergesetzt. RFID gehörte, glaube ich, dazu. Ja, genau, Biometrie war dein Thema. Zusammen mit Starbucks hast du da auch am Anfang die Vorträge gemacht. Wo bist du dann weiterhin geglitten?
Dann bin ich weiterhin geglitten in die etwas klassischere Disziplin des Reverse-Engineering und Bug-Finding, so Exploits-Bauen und solche Geschichten. Und von da ein bisschen weiter zum Source-Code-Auditing. Und als das auch langweilig wurde, habe ich mich wieder mal eines Traums aus der Biometriezeit erinnert. Weil eine der biometrischen Methoden, an die wir nie rangekommen sind, war DNA, Forensik. Und wir hatten aber damals nicht die Mitte und keine Ahnung, wie man sowas angeht.
Also Biometriez schon Methode DNA zur Identifizierung primär?
Identifizierung, ja. Also es wurde halt in den Texten auch immer so mit genannt. Hat zwar keiner benutzt so richtig aus seiner Kriminalforensik, aber es schien halt immer am Horizont so.
Und das müsste man doch eigentlich mal machen können.
Genau, da müsste man doch eigentlich sich mal mit beschäftigen.
Also ihr wart da sozusagen langweilig. Das ist ja eigentlich immer die stärkste Triebfeder des Hackers. Auf zu neuen Ufern. Wir wollen reden über Biohacking, eine neue Sportart am Horizont, kann man sagen. Wie würdest du so das Alter bezeichnen? Ist das schon in der Teenagerphase angekommen oder haben wir es hier eher mit einer Disziplin noch in ihrer Kleinkindphase zu tun?
Ich würde sagen noch in der Kleinkindphase. Also vereinzelte Leute, die man wahrscheinlich in 20 Jahren in einer Geschichte des Biohacking als der erste Biohacker bezeichnen würde, gab es wahrscheinlich auch schon früher. Aber so wirklich abgehoben hat das erst alles so vor zwei, drei Jahren, wo es populär wurde.
Vor zwei, drei Jahren. Und warum wurde es dann auf einmal populär?
Ich glaube, dass wir viel dem MIT und dem iGEM-Wettbewerb zu verdanken haben, weil viele der wichtigen Leute, die da einflussreich sind und sich darum kümmern und es als Open-Source-Aktivität propagieren, kommen halt vom MIT und haben da mitgeholfen, diesen iGEM-Contest anzupassen.
Also MIT, Massachusetts Institute of Technology, schon immer auch eine gute Quelle gewesen für allerlei lustige Hacker und Disziplinen. Und auch in diesem Fall. Aber was, also ich meine vielleicht erst mal so zum Begriff, gibt da ja auch verschiedenste Griffe, die so herumfliegen. Die Wikipedia scheinen sich da auch noch nicht ganz einig zu sein. Wenn man da nach Biohacking sucht, dann landet man eher bei dem Begriff Synthetic Biology, synthetische Biologie. Klingt jetzt sehr wissenschaftlich, Biohacking klingt alles andere als das. Wie würdest du denn so diesen Begriff einordnen? Worum geht es?
Biohacking. Ja. Ich würde es einordnen als einen, ja, ein open source, einen demokratisierteren Ansatz an Biologie im Allgemeinen und die neue Bleeding-Edge-Biologie, also so Genetic Engineering, genetische Modifikationen, im Besonderen. Also das aus den großen Laboren, Unis und Firmen rauszuholen und in Schulen und Hacker-Spaces und ähnliche bürgernahe Inrichtungen reinzubringen.
Aber es scheint generell auch ein heißes Thema in der Wissenschaft zu sein. Das war jetzt bei Computing auch nicht anders.
Synthetic Biology auf jeden Fall.
Was versteht man da drunter? Also Biologie ist ein weites Feld. Ich meine, das ist jetzt irgendwie alles von der Kartoffel auf dem Acker bis hin zu jedem lebenden Wesen. Welche Bereiche der Biologie sind jetzt hier eigentlich besonders interessant? Also klar, DNA ist jetzt schon sozusagen, das war so die Karotte, der du hinterhergelaufen bist. Aber was sind so da die möglichen Disziplinen?
Ich kann dir mal kurz erklären, was synthetische Biologie eigentlich ist oder will. Es ist ein Ansatz, also eigentlich möchte es aus Biologie ein Ingenieursfeld machen, mit dem man schöne Teile hat und neue Organismen zusammenbauen kann.
Also ein Ingenieursfeld, wo es heute im Wesentlichen eine sammelnde Wissenschaft ist.
Also wie gesagt, ein bisschen weg vom Naturalismus, nur angucken, was es gibt, zu einer Ingenieurswissenschaft eigentlich.
Also zusammenbauen.
Zusammenbauen nach bestimmten Regeln.
Im Prinzip ist es so ein bisschen Gott spielen, so ein bisschen mit denselben Bausteinen, mit der die Natur so ihre Systeme entwirft, Pflanzen, Tiere, etc., eigentlich sich desselben Werkzeugkasten zu bedienen und dann auch loszugehen und zusammenzubauen.
Ja, so ein bisschen Gott spielen vielleicht nicht, aber auf jeden Fall Natur spielen. Das ist so die Idee von synthetischer Biologie.
Und wie lange gibt es diesen Begriff schon? Ich meine, gab es den schon immer? War das eher so ein Traum? Und jetzt kommt es erst dazu? Oder ist vor ein paar Jahren mal jemand aufgestanden und hat gesagt, wir könnten ja auch mal was bauen? Und dann nennen wir das jetzt so?
Den gab es noch nicht immer. Ich würde so in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts ansiedeln, wo das erste Mal Leute auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass es ja vielleicht möglich wäre, mit dem Entdecken der DNA. Davor gab es ja eigentlich nur Züchtung als Werkzeug. Und mit dem Entdecken der DNA und der Strukturaufklärung und der Entwicklung von Sequenzierungs- und Synthetisierungstechniken konnte man sich dann auch vorstellen, dass man da vielleicht gezielter eingreifen kann.
Was ja auch teilweise schon getan wird, so im industriellen Maßstabe. Mir fällt da jetzt gleich so hier diese Samenhersteller Monsanto natürlich ein, die da versuchen, genetisch modifiziertes Saatgut unter das Volk zu bringen.
Und damit auch relativ erfolgreich sind.
Ja, leider. Aber das fällt im Prinzip unter synthetische Biologie.
Synthetische Biologie will eigentlich, also das, was Monsanto gemacht hat, ist ein ziemlicher Schrottflinten-Ansatz. Und synthetische Biologie möchte das eigentlich besser kontrollieren können.
Schrottflinten-Ansatz.
Die Techniken, mit denen es gemacht wurde, führen die eine genetische Mutation, die man haben will, ins Genum der Pflanze ein. Aber daneben auch noch beliebig viele andere, die man weder kontrollieren, noch wirklich, von denen man noch wirklich die Auswirkungen verstehen kann.
Warum ist das so ein bisschen, sie benutzen den Hammer anstatt der Pipette?
Na, sie benutzen halt Viren-DNA. Also sie benutzen Viren als Vektoren, um neues genetisches Material in die Pflanze gehen, um einzubauen.
Was meinst du mit, sie benutzen das als Vektoren?
Als Träger sozusagen. Das kann man sich für ein kleines Shuttle vorstellen, wo die DNA drin ist und es wird dann in die Zelle eingebracht.
Mit den Viren wird sozusagen die Mutation herbeigeführt?
Ja, so kann man das sagen.
Anstatt sie selbst durchzuführen?
Also Viren sind ja so, dass Proteinhüllen mit genetischem Material drin sind. Und das genetische Material kann man auch austauschen. Und diese Proteinhüllen sind halt von der Natur schon so schön entwickelt, dass sie gut darin sind, den Zellkerne einzudringen.
Weil das ja die Aufgabe ist von Viren. Genau.
Das heißt, man hat einfach eine bestehende Technologie, Viren, genommen und sie abgewandelt, um halt eigene Zwecke zu verfolgen. Und das funktioniert aber wie gesagt nicht ganz punktgenau. Also man kann nicht wirklich kontrollieren, erstens wo dieses, also man hat dann immer ein Stück DNA, was da eingebaut wird, so ein Gen oder zwei. Man kann aber nicht kontrollieren, wo im Genum die landen. Also sie können auch innerhalb eines anderen Gens landen und das damit deaktivieren oder am Ende eines anderen Gens, sodass man einen Hybrid-Protein am Ende hat. Und das ist auch nicht nur an einer Stelle, sondern an mehreren Stellen im Genum. Und man kann nicht so richtig sagen, was da jetzt eigentlich genau passiert ist mit dieser Mutation. Man kann zwar sagen, ja gut, dieses eine Protein wird jetzt von der Zelle hergestellt, aber was ansonsten noch von der Zelle dann hinterher hergestellt wird, weiß man nicht so genau.
Verstehe, also Monsanto wendet zumindest aus deiner Perspektive zweifelhafte Methoden an, in der Art und Weise, wie sie die Genmodation durchführen. Tatsache erst mal so vorab zum Feststellen ist, es gibt Firmen, die machen das. Monsanto ist die bekannteste und größte davon, aber sicherlich nicht die einzige, die in diesem Bereich versucht, ein Player zu sein. Und das Ganze hat zumindest im Agrarbereich, aber sicherlich auch in vielen anderen Bereichen, die einem nicht sofort klar werden, auch ein großes industrielles Potenzial. Aber darum geht es ja jetzt erst mal, weil das ist ein Biohacking, erst mal nicht, sondern du hast ja im Prinzip dann erst mal so diesen von unten Ansatz, erst mal das Verstehen und das mal gucken zu verfolgen.
Das Interessante ist, dass synthetische Biologie nicht primär, also da geht es nicht primär ums Verstehen. Und ich weiß auch nicht, ob es mir primär ums Verstehen geht, weil dann würde ich wahrscheinlich einfach Molekularbiologie studieren. Mache ich aber nicht. Synthetische Biologie, es gibt Biologiebereiche, die sich primär mit dem Verstehen, diese ganzen Mechanismen beschäftigen, zum Beispiel Systembiologie, gerade wieder Schwärmen kommen. Aber synthetische Biologie, da geht es tatsächlich am ehesten darum, Zellen wie kleine Fabriken zu behandeln und herauszufinden, wie man die am besten dazu bringen kann, das herzustellen oder das zu tun, was man gerne möchte.
So eine Art Farming.
Ja, und das Verstehen nur insofern, wie es einem hilft, genau das zu erreichen.
Okay, Systembiologie.
Systembiologie, ja. Das ist noch ein anderes Feld, was im Prinzip nur ein Wiedergänger der Kybernetik ist, sozusagen. Aber Kybernetik ist so 60er und out, deswegen heißt es jetzt Systembiologie.
Okay, aber Systembiologie machst du auch nicht.
Nicht so wirklich, nee.
Sondern du machst Biohacking. Du bist aber auch jetzt nicht die Einzige auf diesem Planeten, die das macht, sondern es gibt da auch schon so einen gewissen Trend.
Ja, also vor allen Dingen in den USA ist das sehr groß. Da gibt es mehrere Gruppen, die sich regelmäßig treffen. In New York gibt es eine, die sehr aktiv ist, die treffen sich bei den Invisier-Resister-Leuten. Vor einmal eine Woche ungefähr. Genau, dem Hacker-Space in New York. Da werden auch schon die sozialen Verflechtungen mit dem Rest der Hacker- und Makerszene ein bisschen sichtbar. Und in San Francisco gibt es welche, in Seattle und in Boston natürlich.
Also da, wo das MIT ist.
Genau. Und die, was tun die so? Die beschäftigen sich viel damit, erstmal wie man die Technologien, die Grundlegenden, so das Äquivalent zum Compiler und Debugger ein bisschen massentauglich machen kann und für Leihen sozusagen, für engagierte Leihen und Amateure zugänglich machen kann. Und passt denen so damit rum, selber Kameras zu bauen. Also gerade dieses DIY wird dabei bei denen sehr groß geschrieben.
Also es ist ja auch so ein Name, der immer wieder ins Feld geführt wird. DIY Bio, also DIY Yourself, BioLogy sozusagen. Machst du dir selbst. Und wie groß kann man sich diese Community so vorstellen?
Letzte Zählung waren glaube ich so was wie 650, 600 Leute auf der Mail-Niste. Und wie viele aktive Mitglieder, also ich weiß, dass in New York so was wie 10 aktive Mitglieder sind, die sich da regelmäßig treffen. Bis jetzt ist wohl ein bisschen eingeschlafen, bei den anderen weiß ich es nicht.
Also durchaus in der Erwachungsphase ist aber auch nicht so, dass es keinen interessieren würde. Und man gewinnt so den Eindruck, dass da so ein gewisser Zug drin ist. Also dass da so eine gewisse Dynamik entwickelt. Dass Leute da eher dahintendieren, sich damit auch nochmal zu beschäftigen, als dass das jetzt so eine ewige Nische bleiben sollte. Siehst du das ähnlich?
Das sehe ich schon ähnlich. Also es ist auf jeden Fall großer Enthusiasmus da, bei den jeweils Beteiligten. Und bekommt auch viel Dynamik durch diese iGEM-Competition. Weil einfach jedes Jahr 1000, 2000 undergraduate students, also im deutschen System wären es wahrscheinlich Grundstudium-Studenten, die Möglichkeit haben, mal mit genau solchen Techniken rum zu experimentieren, ein bisschen zu spielen unter Anleitung. Und diese spielerische bei dieser Competition auch sehr stark betont wird.
Und wie funktioniert diese Competition? Worum geht es da? Was sind da die Disziplinen?
Also bei der Competition geht es darum, dass die Studenten mithilfe eines Bausatzes, der gestellt wird, genau, das ist halt Teil dieser Synthetic Biology-Initiative, dass es da einen Bausatz an standardisierten Bauteilen gibt, sodass man so ähnlich wie man einen Katalog von Elektronik-Bauteilen auflegt, die sind dann spezifiziert. Da steht drin, welche Betriebstemperatur sie haben und welche Spannung sie brauchen. Das Ziel dieser Standard Registry of Biological Parts ist, sowas ähnliches für biologische Bauteile zu bauen. Es ist eine Datenbank, die öffentlich ist. Die Aufgabe der Studenten in dieser Competition ist, aus diesen Bauteilen, die schon bestehen, und welchen sie selber neu entwickeln, interessante kleine Organismen zu entwickeln, die irgendwas tun. Weiter gibt es da keine Einschränkungen. Das heißt, obliegt es den Studenten, sich irgendwas Cooles auszudenken?
Wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen, also so ein Katalog von Bauteilen? Was ist da jetzt so drin? Also was liegt da jetzt rum?
Verfaulte Eier? Nee, das ist erstmal nur ein immaterieller Katalog, also die DNA-Sequenz, was es tut, für welche Umgebung es geeignet ist. Und wenn man es weiß, mögliche Interaktion mit anderen Bauteilen. Da bricht die Analogie von Elektronik- und biologischen Bauteilen ein bisschen zusammen, weil so eine Zelle ist ein unglaublich komplexes Feedback-Netzwerk von Genen, die sich gegenseitig regulieren. Man sieht da noch nicht so richtig durch.
Also wir reden jetzt von echten, wirklich real existierenden DNA-Ketten, oder ist das jetzt alles nur virtuelle Toolbox?
Beides. Also erstmal der Katalog ist im Internet erstmal als virtuelle Toolbox. Und bei dieser Competition bekommen die Teams dann alle so einen Bausatz mit den synthetisierten DNA-Ketten zugeschickt. So die Grundbausteine.
Was könnte da so ein Element sein?
Ein Element ist zum Beispiel ein Inverter.
Was invertiert der?
Der invertiert, wo zwei Gene sozusagen invertiert, exprimiert werden. Exprimiert heißt also, Gene können ja auch inaktiv sein und einfach nur rumgammeln. Oder sie können tatsächlich in Proteine übersetzt werden in der Zelle. Und ob das getan wird oder nicht, ist halt steuerbar. Und ein Inverter steuert das genauso, dass das so eine XOR, also so eine exklusive ODER-Relation ist. Wenn Gene A wird exprimiert, genau dann, wenn Gene B nicht exprimiert wird.
Das heißt, man baut sich das so zusammen, wie man das auch so dann doch eben so ein bisschen aus Elektronikschaltungen kennt. Da kommt da irgendwie so Strom, da kommt kein Strom, dann hab ich da irgendwie so meine Gatter und die machen dann irgendwas draus.
Und es ist auch ein großes Gebiet bei dieser Eingebem-Competition, halt so Computer- oder Logik-Schaltkreise aus dem...
Aber ist das jetzt sozusagen dann schon... Das ist jetzt sozusagen die eigentliche Ingenieursleistung, dass man Biologie als etwas versteht und einfach so verwendet, dass es solche Dinge tut. Es ist nicht die eigentliche Eigenart der Biologie auch so zu funktionieren.
Ja, das ist überhaupt nicht die Eigenart der Biologie.
Okay, das ist also nicht... Wir reden eigentlich gar nicht von einem Nachvollziehen. Es ist gar nicht so sehr Naturspielen als Natur austricksen und zu anderen Dingen bringen.
Handhabbar machen und beherrschbar machen, so dass man sozusagen eine Unterwerfung der Natur immer wieder...
Verstehe. Aha. Aber alles fängt irgendwie jetzt an auf dem DNA-Level. Also sozusagen all diese Elemente, die jetzt in dieser Registry of Biological Parts drin sind, lassen sich durch DNA beschreiben.
Und sind auch dort durch DNA beschrieben.
Und das bedeutet aber auch, bin da nicht so firm drin, dass sozusagen das System DNA mittlerweile so weit verstanden ist, dass man sich im Prinzip alle möglichen Dinge beschreiben kann und dann aber auch schon von der Beschreibung auf ihre Funktion schließen kann? Oder muss das dann immer so testen? Ich denke mir mal eine DNA aus und dann gucke ich mal, was sie tut. Und dann ordne ich das entsprechend ein.
So weit ist es auf jeden Fall noch nicht verstanden. Also überhaupt nicht. Und die Teile, die jetzt in der Registry schon drin sind, von denen ist halt schon mal irgendwann experimentell ermittelt worden, was sie denn tun.
Wie viele sind das so? 100, 1000?
Ja, so in der Größenordnung 1000, 2000.
Das ist ja schon ganz ordentlich, ne?
Muss man aber dazu sagen, dass bei vielen einfach... Also viele sind gar nicht überprüft. Bei manchen steht explizit dabei, ja, haben wir probiert zu benutzen, hat aber nicht funktioniert. Und ich würde vermuten, dass nur eine Minderheit dieser Teile in der Registry überhaupt zuverlässig funktionieren. Und das kommt halt auch daher, dass man es eben noch nicht so richtig versteht, wie das alles miteinander zusammenhängt und was für Seiteneffekte es noch gibt. Man hat zum Beispiel in irgendeiner Experimentreihe rausgefunden, dass die Änderungen, die in eine Zelle reiningeniert wurden, dass die Zellen eine Tendenz hatten, die alle wieder rauszueditieren. Successive. Und man weiß halt noch nicht so genau, warum.
Also es ist eine sehr flüchtige Wissenschaft zu dem aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Es gibt da noch keine wirklich ewig gesicherten Erkenntnisse. Aber es gibt ja jetzt sicherlich so ein paar Teile in dieser Registry, die auch schon als stabil und beherrschbar und verstanden angesehen werden und die ein paar ganz grundlegende Dinge tun.
Sicherlich, ja. Kann ich dir jetzt aber aus dem Hut nichts sagen, wenn ihr da mal selber drin rumklicken.
Ich versuche mich nur so ein bisschen zu diesem Wesen mal hier zu nähern. Aber vielleicht sollte man an der Stelle auch nochmal auf diese ganze DNA-Geschichte als solche angehen. Wir setzen das jetzt hier in gewisser Hinsicht voraus. Jeder hat das sicherlich schon mal in irgendeiner Form, in irgendeinem Unterricht mal tangiert. Das ist bei mir schon eine Weile her, dass ich mir die Buchstabenketten mal vergegenwärtigt habe. Was weiß man denn und was muss man v.a. wissen, um jetzt auf diesem Level mit diesem Katalog oder ähnlichen Aktivitäten voranschreiten zu können? Was ist das Grundwissend DNA, was man erstmal verinnerlicht haben muss, um überhaupt zu verstehen, was hier passiert?
Eine Sache, die man auf jeden Fall wissen muss, ist, dass Gene eine interne Struktur haben. Das kann man sich vorstellen wie eine Datei in einem bestimmten Format. Da sind halt Steuerinformationen drin und dann Daten und dann wieder ein Stück noch mehr Steuerinformation. Und die sind halbwegs verstanden, muss man aber auch beachten, wenn das irgendwie funktionieren sollte. Man kann nicht einfach irgendeine Sequenz ins Genum eines Organismus einbringen und erwarten, dass er irgendwas tut, sondern man muss schon dem richtigen Format folgen damit.
Lass uns nochmal so zwei Direktories nach oben marschieren. Wir haben so Biologie, wir haben so Zellen und jetzt kennen wir alle 1000 Zoom-Videos auf YouTube, wo man dann beliebig weit runtergeht und irgendwann in der Zelle ist halt die DNA. Und das ist diese Doppelhelix, auf der dann diese, wie nennt man sie gleich, da wurden dann schon die Komposomen drauf aufgereiht sind und davon gibt es dann irgendwie viel verschiedene Stück. Vielleicht erklärst du einfach mal weiter, bevor ich zu sehr ins Schwimmen komme, weil das ist einfach echt nicht mein Gebiet.
Vier Basen, da hinten die Bausteine A, genau, A, B, C und T. Und die sind in Strängen aufgereiht und in einer Doppelhelix organisiert. Und es gibt da diese Komplementärpaarung. Also A paart sich immer mit T und G immer mit C. Und diese Doppelhelix ist dann normalerweise zusammengepackt in Chromosomen. Das sind einfach Strukturen, die durch Proteine in der Form gehalten werden und eine gute, kompakte Repräsentation der DNA sind. Und im Zellkern verlassen wir den Zellkern nie. Wenn DNA in den Zellkern verlässt, ist irgendetwas ganz falsch. Ergo, wenn man irgendeine Modifikation da dran vornehmen will, muss man in den Zellkern irgendwas einbringen oder rausholen geht nicht. Also so richtig so Schnipp-Schnapp-Cut-In-Pace, wie man sich das vorstellt, funktioniert nicht so toll. Sondern es funktioniert dann so, dass man zusätzliche DNA in den Zellkern einbringt und sich darauf verlässt, dass die Maschinerie, die dann dafür verantwortlich ist, den DNA-Strang abzulesen und Proteine umzusetzen, diese zusätzliche DNA auch abliest. Zusammengesetzt aus verschiedenen Komplexen unseres Ribosom liest die DNA ab und übersetzt sie in RNA. Ich erinnere mich dunkel, dass ich das in der Schule alles auch schon mal gehört habe, dass DNA erst in RNA übersetzt wird und dann von RNA in Proteine. Und diese Maschinerie sind Proteine- und RNA-Komplexe in der Zelle, die für verschiedene Aufgaben verantwortlich sind. Eben das Ribosom liest ab von der DNA. Dann gibt es das Pleissosom, was die RNA dann nochmal zerschnippelt, wieder zusammenfügt und auf den Weg schickt. Und danach wird die RNA erst in Proteine umgesetzt oder auch nicht. In unterschiedlichen Konzentrationen, abhängig davon, wie der Zustand in der Zelle gerade ist, von Umweltbedingungen und alles recht kompliziert und verworren.
Das heißt, das eigentliche Produzieren von Proteinen ist dann der eigentliche Vorgang? Das ist sozusagen das, was aus einer DNA passiert. Das ist dann sozusagen die Maschine, die das Leben erzeugt, die andere Zellen hervorbringt oder irgendwelche Dinge damit tut.
Genau. Und was synthetische Biologie tut, ist, diese Maschine zu hijacken und für eigene Zwecke zu benutzen, um Proteine herzustellen, die nützlich sind, irgendwelche Medikamente oder Ähnliches. Man muss die Maschine intakt lassen, weil wir sie selber noch nicht nachbauen können. Und nur irgendwie versuchen, da die eigenen... Es ist so ein bisschen, als wenn man einen Exploit schreibt. Da lässt man ja auch im Wesentlichen das Programm intakt, bringt es aber dazu, eigene Daten zu verarbeiten. Was am Ende dabei rauskommt, was man gerne haben möchte. Was übrigens auch das Gleiche ist, was biologische Viren tun. Die benutzen auch die Maschinerie der Zelle, um sich selber reprätisieren zu lassen.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, die Naturviren sind sozusagen die Hacker der Natur. Die kommen dann irgendwie, die Blackheads, die kommen dann irgendwie... Es gibt ja auch nicht nur böse Viren, aber so hat man ja immer so sein Bild. Und die verwenden einfach den existierenden DNA-Replikations- und Produktionsmechanismus, aber ändern sie so weit ab, dass sie eben was anderes produziert.
Genau.
Andere Zellen, wieder die Viren, etc., böses Zeug, um selber zu überleben. Und der normale Mechanismus ist durcheinander.
Der normale Mechanismus ist durcheinander, im kritischen Fall eben so weit, dass die Zelle selber nicht mehr sich erhalten kann. Aber im günstigen Fall, also es gibt auch symbiotische Viren, sozusagen, die dann irgendwann, also es gibt im menschlichen Genom auch VirendNA, wo irgendwann in der Geschichte der Menschheit mal ein Virus Zellen infiziert hat und die DNA ins Genom eingebaut wurden und von dort an symbiotisch mit der Würzzelle gelebt haben. Also sowas gibt es auch.
Und was sind das so für Effekte, die dann in mir schlummern?
So genau, weiß ich es nicht. Ich bin nur vor einer Weile wieder darüber gestolpert, dass VirendNA in uns allen ist.
Wir sind einfach dauerinfiziert. Hilft wahrscheinlich auch generell dann bei der Diversifikation unserer Spezies wahrscheinlich. Ist das alles gar nicht so schlimm. Du sagst, du hast das auch mal in der Schule gehört. Das heißt, das ist gar nicht so sehr die Voraussetzung, dass man diesen eigentlichen Mechanismus so gut versteht. Man muss jetzt nicht, wenn man es vielleicht mal wieder mit den Computern vergleicht, man muss nicht unbedingt die Vorgänge innerhalb eines Chips vollständig physikalisch verstehen, wie die Transistoren da irgendwie ihre Ströme um die Ecke bringen, sondern es geht eigentlich sehr viel mehr darum, die daraus entstehende Logik nachzuvollziehen und für sich zunutze zu machen, indem man es dann halt programmiert. Und genauso hat man es hier mit so einer Bio-CPU zu tun, die einfach auf Basis einer komplexen, auch von der Wissenschaft noch nicht vollständig verstandenen Vorgehensweise einen Mechanismus in Gang bringt. Und man beschäftigt sich beim Biohacking eigentlich sehr viel mehr damit, dieser Bio-CPU beim Arbeiten zuzuschauen und dann zu versuchen, durch gezielte Eingriffe in ihr Herz, sprich die DNA, Abweichungen von diesem Vorgang herbeizuführen, die im eigenen Sinne sind, weil man daraus dann eine Biomaschine bauen möchte.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall der Ansatz der synthetischen Biologie.
Okay. Hammer. Das ist irgendwie krasse Scheiße, finde ich.
Das ist ziemlich krasse Scheiße. Also auch, sich mit dieser ganzen Maschine zu beschäftigen, die da in einer Zelle arbeitet, ist so, wenn man aus Computer-Hacking und so kommt, sehr faszinierend, weil das zu reverse-ingenieren ist, so als wollte man irgendein Netzwerkprotokoll, was von Cobol-Entwicklern auf Crack entwickelt wurde, reverse-ingenieren. Also man sieht schon, das ist irgendwie Steuerinformation und eine Struktur, und was ich nicht gibt, aber es ist alles so chaotisch und zufällig. Also es ist ja einfach zufällig gewachsen, sozusagen.
Ich frage mich jetzt natürlich, was für Werkzeuge nimmt man jetzt dafür? Ich meine, DNA, das ist ja jetzt nur nichts, gerade was man eben mal auf dem Schreibtisch auseinanderfaltet und dann hält man da mit der Taschenlampe drauf und zupft mit der Pinzette dran rum, das befindet sich dann doch schon auf einem relativ kleinen Level. Was für braucht man denn so als Biohacker für ein Labor?
Also, wenn man erst mal anfangen will und noch nicht so richtig Geld investieren kann, ist die gute Nachricht, eigentlich braucht man erst mal nur einen Computer.
Aha, das heißt, man simuliert erst mal nur?
Man simuliert nicht unbedingt, aber um sich mit den internen, also mit der Struktur von DNA und Gen und so erst mal ein bisschen auseinanderzusetzen und diese Teile zu studieren, reicht ein Computer, was im Internet unglaubliche Mengen an Datenbanken gibt, wo Sequenzinformationen für viele, viele Organismen gibt, mit Annotation schon, also nicht nur die Sequenz, sondern schon, was der Rest der Menschheit darüber herausgefunden hat, wo jetzt Steuerinformationen sind.
Kurz noch mal zum Verständnis. Sequenz, damit meinst du die genaue Reihenfolge der Basen, sozusagen der Gene. Also was ist ein Gen? Ein Gen ist ja nicht eine Basis.
Genau, eine Basis ist der einzelne Bauteil, AGC oder T halt. Eine Sequenz ist einfach die Abfolge dieser AGC-T. Und ein Gen ist...
Eine Funktionsgruppe sozusagen davon.
Die Definition wird in letzter Zeit ein bisschen schwammig. Also ganz klassisch ist es ein Abschnitt auf der DNA, der eine bestimmte Funktion codiert sozusagen. So kann man es einfach mal sagen. Es wird in letzter Zeit ein bisschen komplizierter, wenn man herausgefunden hat, dass Gene verteilt sein können über Chromosomen und dann erst zusammengeschnippelt werden.
Aber im Prinzip, du hast es schon so angedeutet, habe ich es richtig verstanden, ist auch so ähnlich wie beim Computer. Man hat so Daten und man hat Codes. Man hat quasi Programmschritte, die dann von diesen Rybosomen interpretiert werden, als was es zu tun gibt, auf Basis von anderen Basen, die mir dann sozusagen das Datenmaterial darstellen, was man tut. Sodass wenn man zum Beispiel ein Gen hat, was einfach schon mal im Prinzip die richtige Funktion hat, aber nicht auf Basis eines Datenmaterials, wie ich es gerne hätte, dass ich dann einfach das Datenmaterial ändere und dann habe ich das gewünschte Ergebnis.
Wobei das ganz so einfach nicht ist. Wir reden immer ganz optimistisch von Dequenzen und stellen uns als Zeichenketten vor.
So ein Array mit eckigen Klammern und so.
Genau, aber DNA ist eben kein Array mit eckigen Klammern, sondern hat auch noch physische Eigenschaften, die dazu führen, dass DNA sekundär Strukturen bildet, also sich so faltet und sich selber Basen paart und so. Und die sind nicht immer so richtig vorher zu sehen und können dazu führen, dass Sachen, die im Computer total cool aussahen und von der Sequenz her prima passen, einfach nicht funktionieren. So viel zum Thema Computer. Also kann man erst mal mit anfangen und erst mal ein bisschen Orientierung bekommen und auch mal sehen, mit was für Größenordnung von Daten man sich damit beschäftigen muss. Und wenn man dann tatsächlich auf die Idee kommt, dass man so was physisch mal ausprobieren möchte, eben genau der Schritt von im Computer, sieht das alles ganz prima aus, aber funktioniert es dann am Ende auch, ist das, womit man anfangen will, der Compiler sozusagen und ein Debugger. Und als Debugger benutzt man derzeit im Low-Budget-Bereich so eine Art Print-F-Debugging. Zwar Gel-Elektrophoriese.
Noch mal kurz. Gut, also jetzt mal vielleicht auch für die Leute, die jetzt so in der Programmierung nicht ganz so drinstecken. Compiler-Debugger, wir meinen jetzt im Prinzip erst mal als Basisinstrumente. Wir brauchen etwas, um Abläufe überhaupt erst mal zu beschreiben und dann auch zu übersetzen, was der Compiler eigentlich macht. Der nimmt halt Programmcode und führt es in etwas um, was dann von der Maschine ausgeführt werden kann. Also beim Computer eben der Assemblercode oder Maschinencode. Und in diesem Zusammenhang, Compiler, redest du von etwas, was dann DNA-Sequenzen erstellt?
Ja, noch nicht ganz da, weil wenn man Compiler so versteht, dann ist ein Compiler nichts, was man sich üblicherweise leisten kann als Amateur. Es gibt DNA-Synthesizer, die sind aber Schweine teuer. Allerdings gibt es Dienstleistungen, wo man einfach eine DNA-Sequenz hinschickt, so ein Text-File sozusagen, und bekommt dann eine Woche oder zwei später so kleine Röhrchen mit der synthetisierten DNA zurück.
Wobei, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, hab irgendwann mal einen Bericht darüber gehört, solche Firmen, die gibt es, aber die haben natürlich auch ein ex-sicherheitsproblem, weil denen könnte man ja im Prinzip auch wohlverstandene DNA von der Pest und sonstigen Menschheitsplagen schicken und sich im Prinzip massenhaft Krankheitsviren erzeugen lassen. Und das filtern die dann irgendwie raus.
Das filtern die da raus?
Wenn man denen jetzt irgendwie so absurde, vollkommen in ihrer Funktion unverstandene Sachen schickt, was machen die dann?
Das ist eine spannende Frage. Da gibt es gerade relativ viel Streit drum von den besagten Firmen und vor allen Dingen der US-Regierung. Weil die Firmen screenen sämtliche Aufträge, die sie bekommen, gerade manuell. Eigentlich sitzt immer ein gut ausgebildeter, entsprechend teurer Mensch, der sich das anguckt. Ist den Firmen zu teuer, deswegen wollen sie eigentlich auf ein automatisches Screening umstellen. Da ist aber die US-Regierung extrem nervös bei, da ihm das nicht sicher genug ist. Und lustigerweise haben diese Firmen jetzt das gleiche Problem wie seit Jahrzehnten die Antivirenhersteller in der Computerindustrie. Sie müssen anhand einer Sequenz sagen können, ob das eine Schadfunktion ist oder nicht. Ob das böse ist oder nicht. Und große Überraschung, es ist nicht so einfach in der einen wie in der anderen Industrie. Also es bleibt spannend. Aber das ist einer der Vorteile dieser Standard-Registry. Die kann man relativ einfach bekommen, weil die halt bekannt sind und man weiß, was sie tun.
Das heißt, wenn man wirklich sowas dann haben wollen würde und sich bauen lassen wollen würde von so einer DNA-synthetisierenden Firma, dann könnte man sagen, ja hier guck mal da, das ist im Wesentlichen einfach das mit Kennung in der Standard-Registry. Und da weiß man auch, was es macht. Und dann kann der sagen, alles klar, super, das ist jetzt hier nur so ein bisschen Biohackerspielerei. Das kann man zwar jetzt industriell auch zunächst gebrauchen, aber das löst jetzt auch nicht gerade irgendeine Epidemie aus.
Es gibt auch eine Firma, die darauf spezialisiert ist, genau diese Teile aus dieser Registry zu synthetisieren und zu verschicken.
Ah, das lohnt sich schon.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es sich lohnt oder ob die eigentlich gegründet wurde aus dem MIT-Umfeld, um iDream zu versorgen.
Ah, verstehe.
Aber ja.
Okay, ist auf jeden Fall gut. Zurück zu den Compilern. Also wenn man jetzt nicht so eine Firma bedient, sondern seine DNA selber zusammenbauen will, das ist ja das, worüber wir eigentlich reden. Also vielleicht ist Synthesizer dann doch die bessere Bezeichnung als Compiler?
Ich denke auch Synthesizer ist besser. Ich muss sagen, dass ich da noch nicht bin, weil ich erst mal lesend die Bezeichnung habe. Es ist einfacher, billiger und vor allen Dingen auch einfacher, an das Equipment ranzukommen und besser dokumentiert. Also es gibt Dokumentationen darüber, wie die chemischen Abläufe beim Synthesizen von DNA sind, aber es ist nicht so gut dokumentiert wie der lesende Vorgang. Deswegen erst mal lesen, weil man damit auch schon hübsche Sachen machen kann. Und da hat man eben zwei Tools, PCA und Gel-Elektrophorie. Und PCA heißt Polymerase-Kettenreaktion. Polymerase-Kettenreaktion, genau.
Was ist das eine?
Polymerase ist das Enzym, was da so im Mittelpunkt steht. Kettenreaktion heißt es, weil es eine Kettenreaktion ist. Und es löst folgendes Problem. Wenn man DNA aus einer Zelle extrahiert, ist da genau ein, im besten Fall zwei Kopien der fraglichen Sequenz drin. Das ist zu klein, um es irgendwie analytisch einfach nachzuweisen. Deswegen, was man macht, man vervielfältigt mittels der PCR genau das Fragment, was man sucht, so weit, dass man es gut analytisch nachweisen kann. Man fängt mit 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Molekülen davon an, also Makromolekülen, und hat am Ende so ein Zyklus, eine Million.
Also diese Polymerasen, das ist jetzt auch keine neue Erfindung, sondern ein normaler Bestandteil davon, wie Zellen und Veraberungen und so weiter funktioniert.
Polymerasen sind Enzyme, die irgendwann entdeckt wurden in Zellen, und extrahiert und kommenzialisiert, also für den kommenziellen Gebrauch.
Aber jetzt im normalen Umfeld sorgen sie dafür, dass sich die Abinformationen dupliziert Zellen teilen?
Zellen teilen nicht, sondern was Polymerase tut, ist, man nennt es Template-Strang, also ein DNA ist ja doppelsträngig. Es hat aber auch den schönen Nebeneffekt, dass man sie einfach replizieren kann, wenn man einen Einzelstrang hat. Weil wenn man dann so kleine Buchstaben, also die Nukleotide heißen die ja, die Basen, dazukippt, lagern sie sich an den Einzelstrang an und dann hat man zwei Stränge. Und das Einzige, was man dann noch tun muss, ist, DNA hat ja so ein Rückgrat, also so ein Backbone, wo die Basen quasi dranhängen. Und das Einzige, was man dann also Einzelstrang, Nukleotide dazu, was man noch tun muss, ist, diesen Rückstrang auf dem neuen replizierten Strang festklopfen. Und das tut die Polymerase. Ansonsten ist dieser neue Strang nicht stabil und fällt wieder auseinander, wenn es wärmer wird.
Das heißt, diese Polymerase-Kettenreaktion oder PCR, das ist sozusagen ein Vorgang, der sowieso, der sozusagen nicht erst erfunden wurde, sondern der wird einfach nur nachvollzogen, nachgebildet. Und man verwendet ihn dann, um konkret was zu tun, um einzelne Gene zu extrahieren?
Na, um einzelne Regionen auf dem DNA-Strang so weit zu amplifizieren, also zu vergrößern, kann man nicht sagen, aber so weit in der Konzentration zu erhöhen, dass er nachweisbar ist und dass man damit gut arbeiten kann. Das ist eine der, also PCR hat inzwischen 500.000 Anwendungen, aber das ist so die Hauptanwendung, mit der es auch angefangen hat. Und das ist tatsächlich sehr stark angelehnt an den Prozess, der tatsächlich auch in der Zelle stattfindet.
Aber wenn man jetzt noch mal kurz zu dieser generellen Fragestellung Werkzeuge, du meintest ja, mit dem Computer kommt man schon mal weit, aber wenn man jetzt wirklich das tun will, also wenn man jetzt wirklich mal DNA-Modifizieren erzeugen will, was brauche ich da? Muss ich dann erstmal mein Zimmer irgendwie mit Plastikfolie auslegen?
Mit Plastikfolien? Also wenn man dann anfängt tatsächlich, das kommt darauf an, womit man arbeitet. Wenn man zum Beispiel nur mit DNA arbeitet, zum Beispiel wenn man sich mit Forensik oder ähnlichem beschäftigen will, es ist nicht so kritisch, weil DNA ist an sich nicht giftig, da kann nicht viel passieren. Wenn man dann anfängt mit Organismen tatsächlich zu arbeiten, also wirklich ein Organismus genetisch modifizieren will, sollte man sich vorher schon ein paar mehr Gedanken machen, wie man es handhabt. Und zwar, das ist auch eine der problematischen Geschichten an dieser Biohacking-Bewegung. In großen Laboren werden Organismen, also E coli häufig oder Hefe, benutzt, die lange lange für Laborzwecke gezüchtet wurden. Die können außerhalb eines Labors kaum überleben, also die wachsen sehr viel schneller im Labor und sind recht pflegeleicht, aber gegenüber wilden Typen stark unterlegen. Das heißt, wenn die aus dem Labor rauskommen, werden sie relativ bald krepieren. Wenn sie nicht so flauschige, kuschelige sind, als wenn man eine Hauskatze hat, die das ganze Leben Kaviar gefressen hat und dann ausgesetzt wird, die wird es wahrscheinlich nicht lange machen.
Verstehe, ich schaffe es da noch nicht mal über die Straßenecke.
Vermutlich nicht, genau. Diese Bakterienstränge, die kann man die Kaufenlabor einfach. Wenn sich jetzt Amateure aber hinsetzen und beschließen, einfach aus Kloake ihre eigenen E. coli-Linien zu extrahieren, sieht es anders aus.
Dann sind sie schon mal hochresistent.
Ja, die sind dann schon ein bisschen schwerer zu töten. Also die kann man auch töten, aber sie würden halt auch außerhalb des Labors überleben. Und deswegen sollte man sich da vorher ein bisschen mehr Gedanken darüber machen, wie man es so hinbekommt, dass die nicht entfleuchen können, wie man sie umbringt, wenn man mit dem Experiment fertig ist, und zwar zuverlässig. Nicht einfach in Ausguss kippen, solche Geschichten.
Oh man, ich mir vorstelle, dass die Eltern in den 90er-Jahren sich schon darüber Gedanken gemacht haben, was sie ihre 12-Jährigen im Kinderzimmer da so treiben, dass sie das anders gefällig gehalten haben. Das geht jetzt erst los. Gut, das heißt, diese PCR ist jetzt sozusagen eine von zwei Methoden, die du jetzt als besonders versatil beschreibst, um überhaupt erst mal voranzugehen. Die andere war Gel-Elektrophorese.
Genau, Gel-Elektrophorese wird meistens benutzt, um DNA zu lesen.
Was ist das?
Gel-Elektrophorese ist ein Prozess, also eigentlich eine analytische Methode, bei der an ein Flüssigkeitsfeld Spannung angelegt wird. Und wenn da jede Menge Moleküle drin rumschwimmen, die geladen sind, positiv oder negativ, dann wandern die entlang der Spannung durch dieses Feld. Und wenn man Gel benutzt, was so verschiedene große Poren hat, dann wandern, also bei DNA benutzt man es dafür. Lange DNA-Moleküle sind schwerer, wandern deswegen langsamer. Und so kann man mit ein bisschen Tricks die Sequenz eines Stückes DNA herausfinden. Das ist sehr aufwendig in Zeiten, in denen DNA-Sequenzen sehr viel billiger werden. Wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr wirklich lange verbreitet für diesen Zweck. Aber für den Amateur, für den DNA-Sequenzen immer noch außer Reichweite, sind ein schönes Tool, um mal nachzugucken, wie jetzt tatsächlich die Sequenz irgendeines Stückes DNA ist.
Und die Geräte gibt es jetzt schon auf eBay, oder was?
Ja, also beide, sowohl Gel-Elektroporiese-Kästen, das ist eigentlich nur so eine Box, wo ein Laufmittel, also Flüssigkeit, reinkommt und das Stück Gel und dann Netzteil. Und PCR, dafür braucht man ein Gerät, was an sich nicht aufregend ist. Das ist eigentlich nur ein Thermocycler, also es fährt eine bestimmte Temperaturgrube ab. Gibt es auch auf Ebay. Und es gibt inzwischen eben aus dieser DIY-Bio-Community einige Leute, die sich bemühen, sowas in billig und klein und mit USB zu powern, zu entwickeln.
Scary. Und ich stelle mir gerade so das Setup irgendwie dann im Kinderzimmer vor, wenn dann irgendwie so stromdurchflutete Gelkisten, Gelwannen da irgendwie rumstehen und so. Aber was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe ist, brauche ich denn jetzt auch noch ein Mikroskop und brauche ich irgendwie noch so eine ganze Batterie von Mikroskallpellen? Also wie rückt man diesen Material überhaupt erst mal zur Leib? Ich meine, jetzt muss ich mal DNA aus der Zelle rausholen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man die Zelle dann irgendwie so in Plastik eingeschweißt bei Aldi kaufen könnte.
Also was man auf jeden Fall braucht, sind gute Pipetten. Weil damit verbringt man die meiste Zeit in so einem Labor. Dinge von A nach B zu pipettieren. Und das will man auch ein bisschen geübt haben. Und man will auch da anständige Tools, also die Pipetten, da kann man ruhig mal ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben. Weil das auch der Punkt ist, an dem man ein ganzes Experiment versauen kann. Wenn man irgendeine Kontimination mitnimmt oder nicht genug einer Chemie-Kale aufpipettiert. Und die Sachen mit der DNA aus Zellen extrahieren, das funktioniert chemisch. Also die Zellen werden chemisch sozusagen aufgebrochen und gereinigt von Proteinen und RNA und Sonstigem, sodass am Ende nur noch die DNA übrig ist. Und das ist wie gesagt alles chemisch. Das ist einfach nur ein ziemlich langweiliger Vorgang von... Man hat eine Batterie von kleinen Epis, also so kleinen Röhrchen und dann noch eine Batterie von Chemikalien, ein paar Salze, Enzyme und dann steht man da und pipettiert von A nach B. Und dann kommen diese Epis, also diese Röhrchen in den Thermocycler, dann wartet man eine halbe Stunde oder eine Stunde und dann kann man mit...
Das füttert dann diese PCR durch?
Genau, das füttert dann diese PCR durch, was wirklich nur Abfahren ans Temperaturzyklus ist. Und dann, wenn man Glück hat, hat die PCR funktioniert. Wenn man alles richtig gemacht hat, Unglück hat, sagen wir es so. Und dann kann man nachgucken, ob wir, wie gesagt, das Ergebnis, was man haben wollte, so passiert ist. Also es gibt auch Geräte mit Displays, aber die sind teuer. Also so Kapillarelektrophorese-Geräte. Wenn man, ja, ich will nicht ausschließen, dass man Glück hat und sowas für billig irgendwo bekommt. Ich habe mich sehr geärgert, weil ich auf dem Schrotthof einer Behindertenwerkstatt mal so ein Gerät gesehen habe. Mich aber nicht gleich entschließen konnte, es mitzunehmen. Es ist doch etwas größer war, aber es geht. Aber wenn man kein Display, wenn man nicht so ein tolles Gerät hat, was ein Display hat und Auswertungssoftware und Tasten nicht gesehen, muss man das tatsächlich alles von Hand auf dem Geh nachgucken.
Aber was ist denn jetzt sozusagen das Hello World des Biohackings? Also wenn ich jetzt davon ausgehe, ich habe so diese Grundausstattung, ich habe irgendwie ein paar ordentliche Pipetten in meinem Gel-Elektrophorese-Apparat zu Weihnachten geschenkt bekommen. Mami, Mami, ich brauche ein Gel-Elektrophoresegerät. Jetzt steht das ja irgendwie alles rum. Was kann man dann sozusagen tun oder was sollte man dann einmal komplett getan haben, um dann auch so ein Aha- und Glücklichkeitsgefühl zu haben?
Es gibt noch keinen Standard-Hello World, aber was ich ganz interessant fand, war tatsächlich auf eine bestimmte Mutation zu prüfen, also ob man selber eine bestimmte Mutation hat.
Man selbst?
Ja.
Was denn für einer jetzt Rot-Grün-Blindheit oder sowas?
Also es gibt da einen ganzen Katalog von Mutationen, die durch Punktmutation, also wo eine Base verdreht ist, sowas wie, es gibt eine Handvoll Marker für Alkoholismus und für Spielsucht. Ach echt? Und mittlerweile ja.
Auch Internetsucht?
Internetsucht weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, da wurde bisher noch keins charakterisiert. Aber sowas kann man relativ einfach doch mit dem Setup, was ich gerade schon beschrieben habe.
Das heißt, das müssen wir jetzt aber nochmal durchmaschieren. Das heißt, es geht dann sozusagen jetzt erst mal um einen selbst. Das heißt, man schneidet sich dann erst mal eine Fingerkuppe ab. Nein, reicht dann ein Haar oder was?
Ein Haar, wenn eine Wurzel dran ist oder halt so ein Mundabstrich.
Haar, wenn eine Wurzel dran ist, also einmal kräftig ziehen. Wenn ich leiden kann, braucht man auch keine Erfolgserlebnisse. So, dann schmeißt man irgendwie das Haar wo rein?
In Chemikalien, welche, muss ich jetzt nachgucken.
Irgendwelche Chemikalien, die dann was tun?
Die dann die Zellen aufbrechen und den Zellkern auch aufbrechen, sodass die DNA dann außerhalb des Zellkerns da drin rumschwimmt.
Die schwimmt dann so frei in so einem Reagenzglas sozusagen herum? Aber es schwimmt ja auch noch, also alle Teile schwimmen dann.
Es schwimmen gerade noch alle Teile rum, genau. Deswegen muss man diesen Matsch dann noch reinigen, wieder mit Chemikalien, die Proteine und RNA.
Was heißt dann reinigen? Das heißt, man gibt da was hinzu und dann löst sich alles auf?
Man gibt da weitere Chemikalien hinzu, die Proteine und RNA zersetzen.
Das heißt, aus dem Haar bleibt dann irgendwann nur noch so eine dunkle Suppe übrig? Das heißt, da sollte man dann auch möglichst genau tropfen, nicht irgendwie in seiner Hand, sondern...
Ja, und dazu auch die Pipetten, weil es geht da wirklich um Mikroliter, den man da pipettieren muss.
Das heißt, das ist schon ein saugefährliches Zeug, was man da rein macht. Das ist so das, was Menschen so auflöst.
Nee, Haut tut es nicht besonders viel, jedenfalls nicht in den Quantitäten, mit denen man da hantiert, wie gesagt um Mikroliter.
Hab ich nur gerade gefragt, ob das jetzt so das Material ist, mit dem die Bösewichte dann ihre Leichen in der Badewanne zersetzen.
Wobei Badewanne auch eine schlechte Idee ist.
Okay, gut, also bleiben wir nochmal bei diesem ausgerupften Haar. Das heißt, es wird jetzt zersetzt, Zellen werden herausgelöst, aufgebrochen, die DNA schwimmt herum, weitere Chemikalien führen dazu, dass dann auch der Rest sich weitgehend verdünnisiert, aber trotzdem bleibt die DNA als solche erhalten. Aber jetzt ist das ja irgendwie eine riesige Matschepampe von Zeug. Wie findet man denn da jetzt sozusagen das, was man sucht?
Die DNA. Eben genau über diese PCR. Weil die hat die Mischungsverhältnisse. Also man hat am Anfang vielleicht zwei der Makromoleküle, die man sucht, von DNA, also der spezielle genomische Region. Und was die PCR tut, ich weiß nicht, ob man es jetzt so verbal und ohne Zeigen gut erklären kann, wie es funktioniert. Aber es gibt dazu gute Beschreibungen im Internet. Okay, kriegen wir schon hin. PCR funktioniert so, dass man Primer hat.
Warte mal kurz, sehe ich das richtig? Es geht jetzt im Prinzip darum, man hat irgendwie so einen Tropfen voll Fu. Und unter anderem befindet sich da DNA drin. Und die möchte man ganz gerne irgendwie sehen. Da sie aber nur an ganz wenigen Partikelchen in dieser ganzen Suppe überhaupt vertreten ist, benutzt man PCR, damit sie sich selbst permanent repliziert und mehr wird. Sodass man dann irgendwann zwar immer noch Suppe hat, aber diese Suppe im Wesentlichen oder fast nur noch aus eben meiner DNA besteht.
Ja, und zwar nur einer bestimmten Region deiner DNA.
Das auch noch. Aber wie kann man denn da zielen?
Indem man die angrenzende Sequenz kennt. Also wenn du zum Beispiel weißt, du möchtest gucken, ob du eine bestimmte Mutation für Alkoholismus hast. Das ist ja dokumentiert, welche die ist und auch, wie die Sequenz drumrum aussieht. Und wie man diese Sequenz findet, ist dann tatsächlich um die angrenzenden Sequenzen. Daraus generiert man Primer. Da war ich gerade angekommen. Primer sind einfach einstrengige Makromoleküle, also DNA-Moleküle auch, die genau an die Stelle an deinem Genom passen, wo in der Nähe diese Mutation ist oder auch nicht.
Passend im Sinne von, es gibt da so einen Steckermechanismus.
Genau, diese Komplimentarität, das A mit T und C mit G part. Das heißt, du hast genau das Kompliment. Und gibst dann diese Primer in die Suppe dazu. Genaturierst die DNA erstmal? Normalerweise bei Zimmertemperatur ist DNA doppelstrenig. Wenn man sie erhitzt, das nennt man auch DNA-Schmelzen, dann zerfällt die in die beiden Einzelstränge.
Ab welcher Temperatur so?
56 Grad etwa.
Also Brunsenbrenner oder so, muss man jetzt nicht so genau 56, sondern Hauptsache, sich umköcheln.
Man sollte auch nicht viel mehr, weil die Polymerasen, die man später benutzt, zerfällt auch ab einer bestimmten Temperatur. Da sollte man nicht drüber kommen.
Okay, sonst hat man sich alles weggekocht, dann kann man vorne anfangen und muss sich noch mal ein Haar ausreißen.
Und wenn man die DNA1 so streng hat, können halt die Primer rum und sich genau da anlagern. In die Region, sodass...
Achso, man muss sozusagen die erstmal aufbrechen, damit sozusagen der zweite Teil der Helix wegbricht. Die Basen verlieren ihre Komplementbasen auf der anderen Seite und werden dadurch quasi wie so ein Briefkastenschloss auf einmal, oder überhaupt wie sagen wir, ein Schlosssystem sozusagen empfänglich für etwas, was passt, einen Schlüssel. Und dann benutzt man diese Primer, die im Prinzip, wie man die zusammenbaut, das ist nochmal eine andere Frage, denke ich, aber die kommen und haben sozusagen die richtige Basenkettung, um dann genau an der Stelle anzusetzen, der mich interessiert.
Genau, also das ist so eine flankierte Region, also die Region, die du willst und suchst die so...
Von bis?
Am Ende, genau.
Und diese Primer, ich meine, die müssen ja auch erst mal irgendwie zusammengebaut werden. Die gibt es ja auch nicht bei all die.
Die Primer so fast, also es gibt halt standardisierte Primer für wichtige Anwendungen, sowas wie die Merkmale bei DNA-Forensik oder Tests auf genetische Modifikation in Pflanzen, die die halt bekannt sind. Es gibt einen Sack voll Standardprimer, die dann relativ billig zu haben sind. Oder man muss sich halt Primer synthetisieren lassen extra, was aber auch unter Sicherheitsaspekten in der Regel nicht so ein Problem ist, weil es extrem kurze Sequenzen gibt, mit denen man ansonsten eh nicht viel anderes anfangen kann.
So, aber jetzt nochmal, was machen diese Primer? Also die Primer, die docken an dieser aufgespaltenen Helix, also diesem Single-DNA-Strang an den Stellen an vorne und hinten, die mich interessieren. Aber warum ist dieses Andocken von diesen Dingen jetzt für mich, also was bewirkt das, dass die da andocken? Heißt das, dass dann diese PCR nur noch zwischen diesen beiden Primern irgendwie funktioniert und nur noch das dupliziert?
Genau, das ist so der Effekt davon.
Und warum tut ihr das?
Warum, weil sie also...
Warum sind diese Primer für dieses Enzym so wichtig?
Die Primer sind so wichtig, weil diese Polymerase verstärkt ja nur den Rückenstrang, also den Backbone. Und damit hast du halt schon an einer Stelle ein Stück, wo der Rückstrang schon vorhanden ist. Und da lagern sich dann sukzessive die Nukleotide daran an. Nicht irgendwo im Genom.
Weil diese Primer da sind?
Weil diese Primer da sind, genau. Also es wird praktisch konzentriert.
Sind das auch Enzyme oder was muss man sich sagen?
Primer sind DNA-Ketten.
Also auch nur DNA-Ketten?
Also große DNA-Ketten. Das kann man sich wie so ein Seed vorstellen. Seed, also so ein Startpunkt für das Synthetisieren einer neuen Kette. Und daran wird dann eben der neue Strang Lang synthetisiert. Einfach durch diese Basenkomplimentarität.
Okay, also nochmal zurückgespult, Haar ausgerissen, reingetan, mit verschiedenen Lösungen dafür gesorgt, dass alles, was irgendwie nicht DNA ist, weitgehend vermatscht, damit das Ganze für mich auch zu bearbeiten ist. Dann führe ich da diese Primer ein, die im Prinzip so von bis Markierungen sind, um sich an den Stellen der aufgebrochenen DNA anzudocken, die markieren, für welchen Bereich ich mich interessiere. Da nutze ich im Prinzip schon die existierende Forschung, die einfach sagt, okay, hier das Humangenomen, das ist irgendwie weitgehend bekannt, und aha, du willst also jetzt die rot-grün-Blindheit rauskriegen, das ist hier Hausnummer sowieso, und dann gibt es dann auch die passenden Markierer dafür, die kann ich mir dann irgendwie beim Primer-Shop klicken, fülle die dann da mit rein, dann docken die sich da irgendwie an, dann geht das Ganze in diese PCR-Maschinerie, also dieses Enzym, was ohnehin Teil des DNA-Mechanismus in meinem Körper ist.
In deinem nicht, also fast in deinem, aber... Na, bei deinem, also die Polymerase bei Menschen ist halt nicht thermostabil genug. Die arbeitet halt bei so 37, 38 Grad bei Körpertemperatur. Das ist aber zu kalt. Da zerfällt, also man hat das Problem, dass DNA bei diesen Temperaturen auch nicht zerfällt, aber die Polymerase schon. Allgemein bringt es nichts, deswegen benutzt man eins aus einem Organismus, der in heißen Quellen lebt und dessen Polymerase erst bei 79, 87 Grad so.
Okay, aber dasselbe Funktionsprinzip, aber ich nehme irgendwie einen anderen, einen aus Island, wo immer die Geysirer aus dem Boden hervorkommen. So, und dann habe ich das Ganze ja schon ein bisschen heiß gemacht, das heißt, die PCR kommt dazu. Und wie bringe ich die nochmal in Gang?
Das ist einfach so ein Heizblock, sozusagen.
Also erstmal muss man sowieso heizen, um irgendwie erstmal die DNA aufzuteilen und danach muss ich nochmal heizen.
Nee, das ist alles Teil dieses Prozesses. Deswegen fährt dieses Gerät eine Temperaturkurve ab, die genau darauf abgestimmt wird, dass zuerst diese Einzelstränge entstehen, dann die Polymerase ganz besonders gut arbeiten kann. Und erhitzt und kühlt immer.
Das heißt, es macht auch diese ganze Maschine, das ist alles Teil davon.
Also was du tust, ist wirklich nur noch in diese kleinen Röhrchen alles reinpippertieren, was du brauchst. Also die Polymerase, die Primer, die Polymerase, noch ein paar Salze.
Und dann geht das rein in die PCR-Maschine? Genau, in die PCR-Maschine.
Und dann machst du zu und dann kannst du den Kaffee trinken. Genau.
Okay, und da gehört dann auch schon die Erhitzung, die dann zum Aufspalten, das gehört auch dazu?
Genau, weil das in Zyklen funktioniert. Also so ein PCR-Lauf hat, weiß ich nicht, kann man programmieren, aber so 30, 40 Zyklen. Und das ist ein ewiger Kreislauf von Erwärmen, damit der DNA-Strang aufgespalten wird, noch mal ein bisschen abkühlen, wieder ein bisschen erwärmen. Und das wird halt so 30, 40 Mal abgefahren.
Okay, also es ist nicht so wie damals im Chemieunterricht mit Rotkohlsaft und dann füllt man den da ein und dann guckt man sich die Farbe an und dann weiß man, was Sache ist, sondern das Muster einfach so lange vor sich hineiern, bis es dann irgendwann selber meint, dass es irgendwie hinhaut. Das Endergebnis ist, dass dann durch die Markierung der Primer isoliert der Sequenzbereich meines DNA-Strang, der mich interessiert, wird durch diese PCR immer wieder dupliziert und dupliziert und dupliziert. Und dann habe ich am Ende irgendwie so eine Suppe, in der fast nichts anderes mehr ist als das.
Genau.
Und dann kann ich das Ganze unter das Mikroskop legen, oder was?
Ne, unter dem Mikroskop ist nichts zu sehen. Du kannst es dann auf einen Gel laden und es laufen lassen und halt dir angucken. Na, das ist wieder nicht optisch schwer zu erklären.
Jetzt kommt diese Elektrophorese zum Einsatz?
Genau, jetzt kommt diese Gel-Elektrophorese, wo du weißt, wenn es die Mutationen gibt, müsste die Sequenz da drin so und so aussehen. Wenn es sie nicht gibt, halt anders.
So und so im Sinne von Farbe oder Muster?
Im Sinne von Sequenz, also wirklich AGCT.
Aber was gibt denn dieser Apparat heraus? Dieses Gel-Elektrophorese-Gerät ist ja im Wesentlichen so eine Glaswanne mit Gel, wo dann irgendwie die Batterie angeschlossen ist. Dann füge ich da sozusagen meine Suppe rein, die dann bei diesem ganzen PCR-Fahrensinn bei rausgekommen ist und dann schlummert die da drin und dann kommt Strom und dann bewegt die sich, oder was?
Dann bewegen sich die DNA-Moleküle in Abhängigkeit davon, wie lang sie sind. Und das kann man indirekt benutzen, um die Sequenz eines DNA-Moleküls abzulesen.
Das heißt, ich weiß, dass das so und so lang ist und bei der angelegten Spannung müsste es in dem Zeitraum den und den Weg zurückgelegt haben und dann gucke ich da nach?
Ja, oder andersrum. Du siehst, es hat in dem und dem Zeitraum relativ diesen Weg zurückgelegt. Also ist es relativ zu den Referenzstücken ungefähr so lang.
Aber die Länge sagt ja jetzt sozusagen nur aus, ob ich das richtige Stück gefunden habe und nicht ob jetzt ich rot-rüben-blind bin oder nicht.
Ja, deswegen gibt es noch eine andere Technik, bei der man die DNA-Stücken an zufälligen Stellen terminiert und zwar hat man dazu wieder Basen, die aber so modifiziert sind. Also normalerweise ist es bei den Basen so, dass links und rechts davon noch andere Basen andocken können. Es sei denn, sie sind chemisch modifiziert, dann geht es nicht. Das heißt, dann ist der Strang an der Stelle zu Ende. Und du kannst dann halt das indirekt benutzen, um zu sequenzieren, indem du nur A's, also A-Nukleotide dazu gibst, die alle so verkrüppelt sind. Und weißt also, wenn da ein DNA-Strang ist, der 40 Basentare lang ist, weiß ich, dass bei Position 40 ein A ist. Das ist extrem mühsam, aber halt die billigste und gerade einzig erreichbare Variante davon.
Und dann könnte du sozusagen am Ende dieses ganzen Vorgangsthemen dann einfach die Erkenntnis herausstellen, in dem von mir extrahierten Strang, den DNA, wo ich ein bestimmtes Merkmal vermute, habe ich dann sozusagen über diesen Längentast indirekt nachweisen können, dass da jetzt irgendwie ausreichend A oder besonders viel A ist oder besonders viel G oder was auch immer gerade in dem Moment gefragt ist. Und dann habe ich quasi die Aussage damit, ja, du bist rot-grün-blind oder nicht. Das ist mal mein Hello World.
Das ist, wenn dich das anmacht, ein Hello World, das gibt auch...
Ich fand das jetzt schon ganz sexy eigentlich.
Na, mich macht gerade vor allen Dingen diese DNA-Forensik-Frage an. Unter anderem, weil es noch aus der damaligen Zeit mit der Biometrie übrig geblieben ist. Zum anderen, weil es da gerade einen Aufsatz von ein paar Israelis gab vor ein paar Monaten, in dem sie gezeigt haben, dass DNA-forensische Spuren relativ einfach zu faken sind. Und das ist ja dann so ein bisschen geärgert, als diese Aufsatz rausgekommen ist, weil ich mich damit eigentlich beschäftigen wollte, aber noch von anderen Dingen abgelenkt war, so Gelderwerb und Diplomarbeit und so. Und auch die Vermutung hatte, dass es nicht so schwer sein kann, so was zu fabrizieren.
Das ist schon so?
Das ist so, ja.
Das heißt, dieser tolle genetische Beweis für die Strafverfolgung und was nicht alles, auf den jetzt so gesetzt wird, und der ja so sicher ist, der lässt sich sozusagen auch faken?
Der lässt sich auch faken. Also es gibt in dem Paper noch eine Lücke, wo praktisch noch ein Fragezeichen dran steht. Aber diese Merkmale zu faken ist einfach und mit Haus. Also das sind Sachen, die man tatsächlich in so einem Küchenlabor machen kann.
Was heißt das? Heißt das, dass ich ein Haar machen kann?
Nein, das ist der praktische Teil. Die Autoren dieser Studie haben nur dargestellt, wie sie die DNA selber zu modifizieren können, dass sie anders ist. Aber noch nicht, wie sie gedenken, dass in eine Zelle eins oder in irgendwie, DNA ist ja nicht wirklich stabil außerhalb des Zellkerns. Also ein bisschen schon, aber nicht so lange, bis diese Spurensicherung da ist. Deswegen müsste man sich halt noch irgendwas ausdenken, wie man daraus was wächst oder eine wirklich glaubhafte Spur herstellen lässt. Vorgeschlagen wurde da irgendein mysteriöser Glipper, der so ein bisschen wie Körperflüssigkeiten aussieht und die DNA sozusagen schützt. Oder ob man versucht, das in irgendwelche Zellen reinzuklonieren, diese Merkmale, und die dann trocknet und verstreut. Das ist wie gesagt noch so ein Punkt, an über den sich dieser Aufsatz ausgeschwiegen hat, der aber wichtig dafür wäre, das wirklich als Szenario darstellen zu können.
Tatsache ist aber auf jeden Fall daran, wird massiv gearbeitet, von verschiedenen Leuten zumindest, einfach mal herauszufinden, wie man eben jetzt nicht nur, bisher war es ja immer so, oh ja, jetzt haben wir die Gentechnik, jetzt können wir irgendwie alles herausfinden und so. Und man nimmt dann sozusagen diesen Beweis als solchen einfach als gegeben an, aber auf die Idee, dass der dann vielleicht auch schon gefälscht sein konnte, ist so bisher noch keiner gekommen. Und wäre das halt wirklich herstellbar, stellen ja im Prinzip die ganze Beweis-Forensik-Abteilung vor einem riesen Problem. Ich denke auch, ja. Weil sie ja dann irgendwie, naja, im besten Fall geht dann das gleiche Spielchen los, wie in der Computer-Security-Branche heute auch schon, sodass man dann so Gegenmaßnahmen ergreift, um irgendwie zu versuchen zu erkennen, dass es ein Fake ist. Und dann kommen die Hacker wieder und...
Es wird dann, wie gesagt, so ein Wettrüsten. Also haben die Autoren auch schon so ein bisschen versucht, einen Vorschlag zu machen, wie man das besser erkennen kann, also wie man erkennen kann, ob es ein Fake ist. Aber das ist halt auch nur eine Frage davon, ob sich jemand die Mühe macht, das auch richtig nachzufaken, also dieses Merkmal. Und derzeit ist es so, dass 13 verschiedene Merkmale im Genom als Standard so in der kriminologischen Forensik benutzt werden. Und dann kann man sagen, ja, wir müssen halt nur mehr davon benutzen, aber dann kann man halt auch mehr faken. Und das wird dann tatsächlich so ein Wettrüsten. Also es wird recht spannend. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das dann ist, wenn irgendein Anwalt auf die Idee kommt, einen alten Prozess nochmal neu aufzurollen, der aufgrund von DNA-Spuren entschieden wurde. Und zu sagen, aber hätte es nicht sein können. Weiß nicht doch mal.
Dann müssen wir erstmal das Gegenteil beweisen.
Also in Deutschland ist es wohl kein Problem, weil es DNA nur Evidenz ist und kein Beweis. Also es kann kein Urteil nur aufgrund von einer DNA-Spur gefällt werden. Aber in anderen Ländern ist es nicht so.
Puh, na das war jetzt ein ganz schöner Marsch. Das heißt, diese ganze Biohacking-Geschichte ist schon, naja, hat schon sehr viel mit auch wirklich physikalischer Interaktion zu tun. Also man muss da wirklich schon Dinge in die Hand nehmen und in welche Flüssigkeiten eintauchen und vor allem viele Pipetten benutzen und Reagenzläschen schwenken und erwärmen und wieder abkühlen lassen. Was ist denn, du hast ja anfangs diese iGEM-Competition erwähnt. Was waren denn da so die Aufgabenstellungen? Was wurde denn dort gefordert?
Gefordert wurde gar nichts. Es kommt halt immer nur das, was die Studenten sich selber ausdenken. Also die Aufgabenstellung ist wirklich nur, mit den vorgegebenen Teilen und selbst zu erfindenden modifizierte Organismen zu bauen.
Gut, dann fragen wir anders. Was wurde dann gemacht?
Mit was kamen die Studenten? Es gab einen großen Themenbereich, wo Biokomputer, also Logik-Schaltkreise mit biologischen Bauteilen, versucht wurden. Es gab Anwendungen, in denen Bakterien dazu gebracht werden sollten, zu singen. Das ist gar nicht so abwegig.
Das ist nicht abwegig?
Das ist gar nicht so abwegig, wenn man zum Beispiel herausgefunden hat, dass Bakterien tatsächlich kommunizieren über Sound und so etwas wie Antibiotika-Resistenz auch über Schallwellen übertragen können zwischen Kolonien. Ach.
Die sagen sich einfach einmal resistent oder was?
Die übertragen auf irgendeine Art Informationen, die es der anderen Kolonie ermöglicht, dann auch eine Resistenz zu entwickeln.
Oha. Und die Studenten haben dann diesen, also von was für Schallwellen reden wir jetzt?
Ja, sie haben versucht, diese Schallwellen abzunehmen und in Musik umzuwandeln.
Ja, aber in welchem Frequenzbereich bewegen sich diese Wellen?
Relativ niedrig, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, waren es 40 Hertz, aber will ich mich jetzt nicht darauf festklopfen lassen, weil es schon eine Weile her ist, dass ich das gelesen habe.
Zellen, Bakterien, 40 Hertz, was vibriert denn da?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die spannen dann ihre Helix-Strengen wie Gitarrenseiten auf und hauen mal ordentlich in die Bio-Klampe vor oder was?
In die Seiten, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert.
Aber das ist sozusagen ein nachgewiesenes Phänomen, auch wenn man sich das noch nicht erklären kann.
Genau.
Das haut mich jetzt um. Und das heißt, dieser Mechanismus, um sie zum Frequenzschwingen zu bringen, der ist soweit schon erkannt, dass man dafür in der Standard-Registry entsprechende Erzeugerelemente hat oder was? Man muss sich doch auf diese Standard-Registry beziehen.
Man soll, aber man kann auch eigene Teile erfinden. Was die benutzt haben, war, glaube ich, irgendeine Art von Ionenpumpen zu bauen. Zellen haben ja so Ionenpumpen sozusagen, wo sie kleine Löcher in der Zellwand haben. Je nach Umgebungsbedingungen sind diese Löcher auf und da Ionen durchbefördert werden oder auch nicht. Das haben sie gebaut und dann in Musik umgewandelt. Das fand ich mich recht erinnern.
Was haben sie dann gespielt? Neues. Also von Singen kann auch nicht wirklich die Rede sein.
Wie gesagt, die sind alles sehr verspielt.
Oh Gott, Deutschland sucht die Superzelle.
Und was man sich auf jeden Fall angucken sollte, sind die Beiträge der Japaner und Koreaner. Das ist so niedlich. Oh, die haben immer so kleine Animationen von Singen und Tanzen in Zellen.
Jetzt auf den Computer-Animationen?
Auf den Computer-Animationen. Also die Teams sollen ja auch immer erklären, was denn ihre Organismen tun. Und gerade die der Koreaner und Japaner sind immer sehr niedlich.
Aber die waren dann sozusagen auch eher im Singenbereich unterwegs, oder was?
Im Singenbereich und sie wollten irgendwie Bakterien bauen, die sich aufblähen, in Anhängigkeit vom Tageslicht oder so.
Also sprich, auch bei diesem iGEM, das ist alles noch sehr, sehr, sehr grundlegend, was dort stattfindet.
Das ist alles noch sehr grundlegend und es ist auch nicht wirklich wichtig, dass es am Ende wirklich alles funktioniert, sondern im jetzigen Stadium zählt auch Engagement, Idee, Spaß und Erfreude. Es reicht, wenn man vielleicht ein paar neue Teile spezifiziert und beiträgt.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an die Geburtsstunde von Fußball-Robotik, wo dann auch irgendwie so Geräte einfach mal eine Stunde regungslos auf dem Feld standen, mit einem einmal das Bein gehoben haben, hingefallen sind und das...
Und alle haben applaudiert.
Ich meine, es steckt ja auch eine ganze Menge drin. Abgesehen jetzt von der technologischen Herausforderung ist ja Bio und Genetik auch schon immer so ein Teil der Science-Fiction-Kultur und Technik-Vision gewesen. Es gibt ja auch zahlreiche Filme, die da auch immer wieder genannt werden müssen, was weiß ich hier so, Gattaca, die natürlich vor allem auch immer gesellschaftliche Fragen aufwerfen, so das übliche, was bedeutet das, wenn wir irgendwie auf diesem Level Modifikationen vornehmen können oder was bedeutet es überhaupt schon, auf diesem Level alles auslesen zu können? Nicht wahr? Diese Vorauslese, diese Möglichkeit, Krankheitspotenziale zu erkennen, das wirft ja große Fragen auf. Gepaart dann eben auch noch so mit dieser generellen Paranoia der westlichen Welt, so Homunculus, wir bauen uns unseren eigenen Menschen, und irgendwie Frankenstein und ähnliche Monstervisionen. Treibt dich das irgendwie um, oder ist das...
Das ganze Bio-IT-Geschichte. Auf einem abstrakten Level schon, aber nicht so, dass es mich jetzt irgendwie davon... Also es bringt mich schon dazu, darüber nachzudenken, was ich mache. Aber nicht so, dass es mich wirklich abhält und dass es mich zu der Ansicht bringt, dass man sich davon fernhalten muss. Aber so abstrakt interessiert es mich schon, und auch als Motivation für diese ganze Biohacking-Geschichte. Weil eine mächtige Technologie, die nur in Händen von Industrie und geschlossenen Forschungslaboren liegt, ist gefährlicher als eine mächtige Technologie, die demokratisch verteilt ist, würde ich behaupten wollen.
Ja, würde ich behaupten wollen. Man ist natürlich nachvollziehbar. So oder so muss man davon ausgehen, dass dieses Wissen erworben wird. Das haben wir bei Computern auch schon gelernt. Und da war ja auch immer so dieses, ach naja, das ist ja alles viel zu kompliziert für euch. Und wir wissen ja schon, was gut für euch ist. Grundhaltung in der Industrie oder eben dann auch beim Starte. Was dann, sagen wir mal, für die informierte und interessierte Jugendbanden im Digitalbereich schon immer klar war, das werden wir auch schon irgendwie rausfinden. Und wartet nur mal, wenn es soweit ist, dass wir das wissen, dann wird es halt sehr unangenehm. Die Auswirkungen hat man wirklich in zahlreichen Fällen immer wieder beobachten können.
Weil es vielleicht nicht mehr in so eine Drohung führt, so wartet mal ab, und dann wird es unangenehm, sondern einfach wir wollen auch, lasst uns gefälligst auch mitspielen.
Es wird unangenehm, nicht als dass man selber eine Bedrohung darstellen möchte, sondern nur so ihr verhindert darüber, dass man einfach offen darüber nachdenkt, was die Implikation sein könnte. Und wir übernehmen das jetzt mal. Und dann haben wir halt diese klassische Hacker-Problematik desjenigen, der halt die böse Botschaft überbringt und dafür dann die ganze Zeit mit schimmeligen Kuchen beworfen wird, bis dann irgendwann mal alle einsehen, dass es vielleicht doch besser gewesen wäre, gleich zuzuhören. Vielleicht wiederholt sich halt die Geschichte in diesem Biohacking-Bereich auf ähnliche Art und Weise. Ich fand zum Beispiel deine Eingangsfeststellung mit Monsanto, was ja schon fast schon das Meme des Bösen ist. Wenn man halbwegs informierten Kreisen Monsanto aufmacht, dann fangen ja alle an, gleich zu stöhnen. Ach ja, und die Unterdrücker und so weiter. Das stimmt ja auch alles. Also aus meiner Perspektive zumindest, die sehen das sicherlich anders. Aber ich fand deine technische Sichtweise an der Stelle sehr interessant, zu sagen, die mit der Schrottflinte. Das ist nicht nur sehr böse, was sie da machen, sie machen es auch noch schlecht.
Also es ist schon State of the Art, was sie da gerade tun. Aber eigentlich ist es schon wichtig, dass es dann informierte Bürgerbewegungen gibt. Zum Beispiel könnte man diese ungewollten Mutationen, die man nicht beeinflussen kann, schon mal analysieren, bevor man sowas auf den Markt bringt. Das ist aber nicht passiert und wird auch von den entsprechenden Behörden nicht gefordert. Analysieren auf was? Also was man jetzt eigentlich mit dem Organismus wirklich getan hat, bis auf das, was man wollte. Im Fall von den Monsanto-Pflanzen war es so, dass noch Jahre später irgendwelche Mutationen von Forscherteams veröffentlicht wurden, von denen Monsanto selber nichts wusste. Was aber auch nicht Teil des Zulassungsprozesses ist. Da ist es schon nützlich, eine technisch informierte Öffentlichkeit zu haben, die sowas fordert. Greenpeace bemüht sich da ein bisschen, aber es könnte durchaus mehr sein.
Es gab ja auch eine ganz bekannte Geschichte mit dem Künstler Steve Kurtz, Critical Art Ensemble. Das hat ja auch einen gewissen Bezug zu dieser Biohacking-Geschichte.
Ja, der hat es eben für seine Kunst sich damit beschäftigt. Mit Biotechnologie ist er auch nicht der Einzige, da gibt es inzwischen einige Künstler. Da gab es ja vor Jahren diesen Eduardo Kak, der dieses leuchtende Kaninchen gebaut hat. Und Steve Kurtz war aber einer, der sich damit beschäftigt hat und dafür auch mit Hochschulen und Professoren an Hochschulen kooperiert hat. Und der hatte wahrscheinlich den schlechtesten Tag ever, weil seine Frau, also er hat mit seiner Frau Hope gerade an einem Projekt gearbeitet für eine Ausstellung. Entsprechend sah es bei ihm zu Hause aus, überall Reagenzgläser und Petrischalen. Und seine Frau hatte einen Herzinfarkt und ist daran dann auch gestorben am selben Tag. Und die Rettung, die kam, hat sich im Haus umgesehen und fand das alles höchstverdächtig und hat das FBI informiert. Auch wenn sie ihn gleich mal mitgenommen und mehrere Stunden befragt haben und ihm Bioterrorismus vorgeworfen. Und er dann einen ewig langen Prozess am Hals hatte, der glaube ich erst letztes Jahr überhaupt abgeschlossen wurde. Also 2004 war, glaube ich, 2003, 2004 dieser Vorfall. Und erst letztes Jahr ist er davon am Ende frei gewesen, hat dabei auch ziemlich viel Geld verloren. Und am Ende haben sie ihn, glaube ich, überhaupt nur wegen Mail-Fraud, also Postbetrug, angeklagt, weil sie sonst nichts... Weil da war halt kein Bioterrismus, war halt harmlos Kunst. Und der Mail-Fraud kam daher, dass er Proben und Reagenzien und Chemikalien zugeschickt bekommen hatte von einem Professor an der Uni, was der nicht wirklich hätte tun müssen und der halt eine Privat-Adresse nicht hätte schicken dürfen. Und deswegen hat er sich jetzt jahrelang mit so einem Blödsinn rumschlagen müssen. Dabei, wie gesagt, viel Geld verloren, viel Nerven und viel Zeit. Da gibt es auch einen Film zu, der ist alles dokumentiert. Strange Culture, glaube ich, heißt der.
Genau, wo dann auch seine Arbeit vorgestellt wird. Ich habe jetzt gerade vergessen, warum es eigentlich ging bei seinen Bio-Geschichten, aber er ist dann auch, glaube ich, auf irgendwelchen Testinseln gefahren, wo Bio-Experimente unternommen wurden und das waren auch die Dinge, die er in seiner künstlerischen Arbeit thematisiert hat. Und auch so Monsanto und ähnliche Geschichten.
Ich kenne von ihm im Wesentlichen dieses Buch, was es Critica Art & Sample veröffentlicht hat, Molekular Invasion, was sehr lesenswert ist. Und auch so ein bisschen Ideen aufwürft, manche auch ein bisschen abenteuerlich, aber Ideen formuliert, was denn so eine Bürgerbewegung Biotechnologie tun könnte, was sie für einen Einfluss haben könnten und warum sie vielleicht notwendig ist.
Ist sie nötig?
Ich denke schon.
Und was sollte sie tun?
Na im Wesentlichen analog dem, was Computerhacker heute tun, technische Kompetenz und damit Auswirkungen auf Gesellschaft und technologische Entwicklung begleiten, kritisch begleiten.
Aber auch so mit Spaß am Gerät?
Auf jeden Fall mit Spaß am Gerät, ja. Du hast jetzt immer versucht, draus zu finden, was man denn damit machen kann und Hello World, aber ich muss gestehen, dass ich an genetischen modifizierten Organismen an sich jetzt erstmal nicht so primär interessiert bin. Ich finde halt diese DNA-Furenz-Geschichte und analytischen Varianten erstmal spannender. Und das ist halt für mich gerade so der Spaß am Gerät.
Aber du hast ja auch vorhin noch, glaube ich, im Vorgespräch angedeutet, da gibt es ja diese Community, die sich in New York trifft, bei NYC Resistor, auch so um diese ganze Maker-Bot-Bripettes-Community herum, die dann auch schon überlegt, jetzt diese Technologien einzusetzen, um die dort in den Maker-Bot-Verwendeten Klebstoffe zu optimieren. Ist das irgendwie jetzt nur so ein feuchter Traum?
Ich würde es als ambitionierten Traum bezeichnen. Also dieser McKinsey-Kaul hat halt gesagt, dass er es gerne machen würde, und Bakterien so engineern, dass sie solche Klebstoffe herstellen können. Ist, glaube ich, eher eine Spielerei und so ein bisschen, erstmal sich ausprobieren und ein bisschen rumspielen. Und so der Enthusiasmus, der dann am Anfang in jedem neuen Feld ein bisschen hochkocht.
Das machen wir. Naja, man muss sich ja auch erstmal große Ziele stecken, um dann auf dem Weg eine Menge Spaß zu haben. Was würdest du denn so jemanden, der sich so von diesem Thema tangiert sieht, und das interessant findet, so als Einstieg raten?
Als Einstieg?
Also womit, was sind so die Ressourcen, die man sich auf jeden Fall als erstes anschauen sollte? Also ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Standard-Katalog, dieser Bio-Dinger schon das Richtige ist.
Also auf jeden Fall in und um iGEM, weil die auch so Protokolle geschrieben haben und Tutorials und um iGEM herum findet man glaube ich relativ viel Material, womit sich auch Anfänger mal gut orientieren können. Und ansonsten, wer die Möglichkeit hat, sollte mal versuchen, ob nicht an der lokalen Hochschule man irgendwie in die Praktika reinkommt. Weil gerade so Sachen wie Pipettiertechniken und so, kann man alleine lernen, sind aber Material und zeitaufwendig. Wenn einem halt nie jemand sagt, was man falsch macht. Und da alleine drauf zu kommen, ist extrem viel Arbeit. Deswegen, wenn man irgendwie kann, an der lokalen Hochschule oder wer in Wien wohnt, das Open Lab mal besuchen.
Was ist das?
Das Vienna Open Lab ist im Biotech-Center St. Marks Teil der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit anscheinend. Und die bieten so Kurse an für alle Altersstufen. Also von 10 bis 17 plus, wo man ein bisschen rumspielen kann. Also gibt es Kurse, in denen man einen DNA-Forensikversuch machen kann und Verdächtige identifizieren oder Lebensmittel mitbringen und gucken, ob da genetisch modifizierte Pflanzen dran beteiligt waren. Und da gibt es eben Betreuer, das sind meistens Studenten der Molekularbiologie, die dann rumgehen und den Leuten erklären, wie sie die Pipetten halten sollen und so.
Dann gibt es ja noch so dieses Do-It-Yourself-Bio-Block.
Genau, das ist eine gute Quelle, aber besser noch ist die Mailing-Nummer dazu. Die ist sehr aktiv. Da ist, wie gesagt, auch viel Spinnerei und hochtrabende Träume dabei, was ganz lustig ist, aber dann vielleicht erstmal für einen Anfänger ein bisschen einschüchtern wirken kann. Dann, wem das passiert, lasst euch gesagt sein, die machen auch nur fünf Prozent von dem, was die da zählen.
Alles Angeber. Da gibt es das, ich sehe gerade, da haben sie auch noch eine Google-Map mit Local Groups. Da ist dann jetzt hier im Norden gerade nicht so viel zu holen, aber in München kommt es ganz dicke, Regensburg und Mannheim. Es ist hier noch so eine Barke eingehauen. Budapest, Milan.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie aktiv die wirklich sind, oder ob das ein Anzeltstelle ist.
Falls jemand in der Nähe einer solchen Nadel wohnt, wo auch immer ihr Chaosradio Express hört, das könnte ja vielleicht für euch auch eine Anlaufstelle sein.
Und besonders an Leute, die in Wien und Umgebung wohnen. Ich suche auf jeden Fall Wegbegleitern.
Die Bock haben, mitzuschwenken.
Mitzuschwenken, genau.
Super, Lisa. Ich denke, das war jetzt mal ein ganz guter Einblick hier in die Bio-Welt. Kann man noch irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen zu erwähnen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ist gut. Das heißt, wir haben ein umfassendes Thema abgerockt, hier in einer 1,5 Stunde. Das ist super. Vielen Dank. Das wollte ich schon lange machen, das Thema hier, um einfach mal wieder so eine ganz andere Richtung aufzuzeigen, zeigt auch irgendwie so Hacking als Basis-Disziplin scheint auch irgendwie unendlich zu sein. Also da kommt immer wieder jedes Jahr wieder was Neues, wo man so diese Grunddisziplin drauf anwenden kann. Jetzt halt auch auf das eigene ausgerupfte Haar. Ja, spannend. Vielleicht gibt es demnächst dann so Maschinen im Supermarkt, wo man dann so sein Haar reinwerfen kann.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber im Internet schon eher.
Wo man sein Haar ins Internet reinwerfen kann.
Genau, einfach in den CD-Laufwerk reintun und dann...
Das ist doch bestimmt gefährlich. Na gut, das war's. Viel Spaß beim Zuhören von all den anderen Sachen, die demnächst noch kommen und schon gekommen sind. Ich sage danke, Lisa. Und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.